-Your girls are 4 and 2?
-They are 4 and 2.
-And, now, I'm assuming
they're not gonna see this film,
but have they seen you on film?
And how do they react
when they see you?
-My daughters, in general,
loathe to see me on-screen.
-Uh-huh.
-In general, you know?
I know, when I was
doing "Mary Poppins,"
I'd even FaceTime my daughter,
and she'd be like,
"Take that silly old
Mary Poppins wig off."
She was like,
"I like your blond hair."
-That's lovely.
-But, actually, we were having
a Super Bowl Party,
and the trailer for
"Quiet Place" came on,
which is terrifying.
-Yeah.
-And Hazel sort of wandered in
with a hot dog in hand.
And she goes like this --
She goes, "Whoa."
That's you, Mommy."
And I was like, "Yeah."
And then there was
a bit where I scream.
I don't know if
anyone's seen the trailer,
but I'm literally like [screams]
at the end of the trailer.
And she -- You could see
her brain exploding.
But, instead,
she went, "Ha...cool."
And then, like, walked out
and never talked about it again.
-Well, that's the key
to parenting is --
when a traumatic thing happens,
just let them
deal on it on their own.
-Listen, that's how
I was raised.
That's like the British way.
-That's the British way.
They know something
painful's happened to you.
Give it 10 years.
-Sweep it under the carpet.
Yeah.
-Are you -- You must be excited
for them to see "Mary Poppins."
-Well, they are in love with
Julie Andrews' Mary Poppins.
-Okay. And had they
been in love --
I mean, I guess they're not
old enough to have been
in love with it for a long time,
but how long have they seen --
-Well, I never
showed it to them
during my shooting of the film,
partly 'cause I just selfishly
didn't want to be so distracted
by how brilliant Julie Andrews
was in the role,
already feeling that there was
this, like, iconic boulder
that I had to, like,
move aside to play this part.
-Were you worried that, like,
your kids will see this one
and be like, "You're our
second-favorite Mary Poppins"?
-Oh, I'm not even on the list.
They're, like, creepy obsessed
with Julie Andrews now, yeah.
-That will be a terrifying
moment, then, for you.
That will be scarier than
"A Quiet Place,"
having to watch
your kids react to it.
-Yeah, I just don't even think
they should see "Mary Poppins."
Like, they should
never watch it.
-This will be your third film
with Meryl Streep.
-I know.
It's like, "Get your own movie."
You know what I mean?
-Exactly.
Thank you for saying that,
'cause I thought the same thing.
-Stalker.
Yeah, and we always play people
who sort of loathe each other
in the films that we do.
-Is there truth to the rumor
"The Devil Wears Prada" --
There might be another
"Devil Wears Prada"?
-I mean, I would love it.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We all would.
-Did you know Stanley Tucci
is my brother-in-law?
-I did know that Stanley Tucci
was your Brother-in-Law.
-He, like, wormed
his way into the family.
-But he wasn't during
the first "Devil Wears --"
-No. So, we met on
the first movie.
I'm talking about like
there is another movie.
We met on the
first "Devil Wears Prada."
And I just loved him so much,
so he was at our wedding
and then met my sister.
-That's unbelievable.
-I know.
-And they've been married
for a while now, right?
-They've been married --
I don't even know how long.
-Too long.
-Too long. Yeah.
And when you met John, he was
already on "The Office," yes?
-He was, yeah.
-And were you aware of
that show when you met him?
-I was sort of aware that
he was vaguely recognizable,
but I was a huge --
-That's so romantic.
-Yeah. It was like...
"You look blurily familiar."
Yeah. But I was a big fan
of the British "Office."
-Uh-huh.
That's what the people on the
American "Office" love to hear.
-Yeah, exactly.
And then I sort of binge-watched
the American "Office"
and loved it.
-And how did you guys meet?
-It's, like,
kind of a sad, lame story.
You know, not sad,
but it's just kind of lame.
I mean, I was in a restaurant.
He was in the restaurant.
I was sitting with
a mutual friend.
This is our romantic comedy.
This is it. Write it!
-This is Paul and Meredith.
-And my friend Gray goes,
"Oh, my God.
There's my friend John."
And that was it.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-And he came over to the table?
-Guys, it's golden.
It's cinema gold.
-It is really good.
Did he -- I'm sorry to ask
for the logistics to this.
Did he then come over and
eat his meal with you?
-No. He was actually sitting
with our friend Justin Theroux.
-Okay.
-And then he abandoned Justin
and came over to come
and talk to us.
He did not eat.
He just stood there
and made me laugh. Yeah.
-There you go.
And it's worked out.
-He just did a bit.
-And all these years later...
And did you know right away?
I'm sorry to dig in here.
-I kind of did.
-Yeah.
-That's good.
-Am I speaking to "Us Weekly"?
I love you. I'm sorry.
-I just want to make it clear
that you guys, as stars,
are just like us.
-I know.
I am just like you guys.
Yeah.
-But I'm so happy.
-It really is -- I mean,
for waiting to see you guys
work together, I never would
have predicted this film.
And it just so wonderful
that you guys did it.
-It's so disturbing.
-Yeah, it's really disturbing,
but it's really great.
-It's so good.
I'm thrilled you love it.
It's sort of been
overwhelming, actually,
'cause we were really nervous
to work together,
and terrified --
John, in general,
was sort of terrified of, like,
how people will view this film
or whether they'll accept it.
And people have just been
incredible about it.
They just love it.
-Well, they're right.
It's really wonderful.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It's just a delight to have you.
-Hey, anytime.